is there any sports you guys did before
that you have like again yeah uh rugby
Fox rugby yeah rugby I actually like
very rich football I hate it I hate to
dream football I like soccer uh no no
Joe you're in England you're in England
Joey it's [__] soccer in it because I
was I was always the goalie and I am for
some reason that checks out I'm [__]
checks I was the only kid that didn't
mind just eating [__] and that is
literally the goalie's job
that's why it's so perfect for you I
don't know oh my God I I was I was like
I'm I was like trying to imagine I
cannot imagine kind of playing football
and as soon as you mentioned goalie I
was like yeah actually checked out I was
always just like I was always pretty
athletic uh but I just they were like
all right we need someone who doesn't
mind jumping they're putting their face
first into someone's feet and I was like
all right I'll do it uh I loved it uh
and then they also because it was always
it was the UK so it was always rainy and
muddy yeah you always got the most dirty
it was horrible yeah before every
football match because I was like so is
this rank door yeah I was super invested
but then I happened to join uh when I
when I was they needed a goalie and I I
think I was the only one who like doing
goalie so yeah I'll be a goalie and my
dad was really happy that I was playing
in a football team he's like oh my God
that's my boy this is so she's such a
British man yeah uh and um yeah it just
happened to be the one year where our
team was cracked it's like they were all
they were all very very good footballers
and so I I would play football we were
in this games and I would just be there
for like 40 minutes doing nothing just
standing in the cold I wouldn't even be
warm because I'm just waiting for them
to the ball never came to our side of
the pitch right and I'm like man this
sucks you're the easiest job ever yeah
it was the easiest job ever and then I
remember one time because I was just
zoned out because the ball never came uh
that the ball just came by and I just
completely ignored it it went in because
I was just standing there because I just
didn't I was like I was like I was
thinking about what like play video
games later I was like oh yeah and then
I heard they're like and I hear that
goofball like started in front of me and
went in and I just wasn't paying
attention I got so much [__] for it an
unbelievable amount of [__] damn uh and
I was like oh yeah I forgot I have to do
this job sometimes yeah
you literally just went NPC mode yeah
pretty much you went AFK bro yeah I was
so bad at kicking it as well so they I
would always give to someone else to
kick because they couldn't kick the ball
I was so bad yeah I I would just jump at
it yeah did you have a sport you played
uh basketball I think uh I think I think
I briefly mentioned this but I was on
the basketball team in school but a
complete accident just because they
needed someone tall and I just happened
to be tall and uh would you do it again
[Laughter]
yeah
I mean I was never really that good at
football
um but that's what I actually really
enjoyed was hockey I don't know why
um no just like
we have we have Canadians watching this
you can't say hockey they get really
offended if you refer to that as hockey
well they can they can have that [__]
ice hot gardening field hockey no I mean
hockey is just hockey guys right right I
mean [__] hockey guys you know the
sport in the Olympics guys come on we
had neither in Australia so yeah you had
AFL right yeah we had AFL I play AFL
again like rugby yeah but AFL was I
don't know AFL is better in my opinion
because I think I got hurt less in AFL
they're like AFL AFL was more tough
because there was way more running and
like kicking involved whereas rugby was
just like if you were a little skinny
Asian boy like I was then you would be
sensible you would be no you it was
always for me after you know during
school if we were doing like a rugby
game together in the in the schoolyard
it'd be like all right Joey you're the
skinniest and the fastest so you're
gonna be at the wing and I was just like
okay and the problem was was that it
would always come over to the wing and
then there'd just be these dudes who
were just like three times my size who
were like I'm going to [__] destroy
you yeah but there's no better feeling
than sprinting into someone and and like
juking them yeah dude whenever I pull
off like a devil bat ghost I'm just like
it's just like let's go it was such a
rewarding fit I wanted to be toxic on
League of Legends I was like man if only
I could turn around and talk [__] to
this guy after I went past him
well the few times I did get hurt and uh
did get tackled I was just like yeah
never again
during the first time you as a kid that
you realize you could get hurt
uh as a kid I was pretty like fearless
and then that I remember I had one
injury that really scared me and I was
like oh oh it really hurts when you fall
or get hurt no I think I had that men I
had the opposite mentality of like I was
such a [__] where I was just like I
don't want to do anything that
potentially gets me hurt and I think
that's why I avoided getting seriously
injured as a child but surely there must
have been a point where that taught you
pain right yeah because as a kid you're
pretty like yeah when my sister would
beat me up maybe
that's when you realize that's what I
realized like you know my brother and
sister like you know just [__]
bantering and then it would start a
fight and then someone would throw a
hand and then obviously the other one
would fight back and my sister was just
like no holds but I'm gonna [__] you up
I I gotta ask because you're younger
than you yeah she beat you up yes what
the [__] she totally beat me up because
she
she let out all the frustrations
yeah exactly exactly okay I gotta ask
because you know I I I don't get I never
got this experience as like an only
child but it seems like every time I
talk to someone who had siblings
um they just was like a moment in your
life where you went from like beating
the [__] out of each other just like I
kind of just like realizing one day
actually they're kind of [__] cool no
you always think that and it's like
you're when you're at home you just when
you're around people all that time you
just get angry but it's like it's like
if I was fighting my brother and someone
else tried to like punch him I would we
would both turn it's not like like I
think in your head you're thinking like
oh during childhood you hate each other
and then as adults you're caught no it
was literally every other day it would
change yeah it was like one morning you
would wake up and be like God my sibling
is an absolute [__] and then the next
day you'd be like no they're the best
which is why it's like really cool in a
way that like because it I guess living
with like three other people your age
must be such a different Human
Experience to having yeah I feel I feel
Conor had a very different experience to
me because you you had three brothers
you're all three brothers and there was
a lot more of you guys right whereas I
only had a sister so well because I mean
I had to learn to share things and that
was I hated that
was like I I saved up for an Xbox yeah
and suddenly they wanna they wanna play
on it and I only get two hours of my
Xbox that doesn't feel fat but I had to
did you get how many Downs uh yeah of
course of course how many Downs are a
thing as well uh right which is pretty
wired terrible fashion since my entire
life because I was just used to wearing
what I was given yeah and I kept that
mentality going into adulthood and then
you become a YouTuber and then people
send you merch you're like all right
cool I just want to wear this the cycle
continues yeah
some Henry damage just in different
formats yeah yeah I mean you it's just
it's such a bizarre thing to think that
I I had that experience and just can't
you didn't and I'm like I couldn't
imagine did you did you did you what
like what was the point where you kind
of like start treating each other
with respects I suppose I was like
thinking about how to work when you
leave when you leave yeah when you leave
yeah it's when both of you leave your
parents house or one of you leaves and
you come back you're like man I actually
kind of Miss yeah
totally uh you know like now that I
don't see my brothers all the time you
know it's I'm like man I wish I got to
see them more yeah yeah no totally
you are you never know what you don't
have uh what you're having to you don't
have it but it's nice right absolutely
if you think about it it's like it's
like having like a of course like
another you who's experienced everything
you've experienced but slightly
different yeah and they're like really
cool because like I'm really I'm really
obviously I've already had a really good
relationship with my parents but it's
like it'd be cool to have it's cool that
I have someone who's like similar age as
well who's has the exact same kind of
experience yeah I don't know it's a
really weird way did you ever have a
point where you're like I [__] hate
this [__] you know I I I was like oh
totally 100 yeah yeah yeah absolutely
like I think it's more more often than
not you know especially while you're
growing up and you're still trying to
like you haven't even figured yeah you
haven't even figured yourself out at
that point let alone trying to
understand someone else as well like
especially one who is living with you
you know every day like that was tough
and like yeah we'd constantly get into
fights but then you know we would always
have this thing where it's like doesn't
matter how bad the fight was the next
day we were always chill about it like
we wake up and it was like it's nothing
happening well
your parents had to make you like makeup
oh yeah yeah like my dad was like I will
beat you up if you don't get back
together with your sister later
yeah I would beat you up if you don't
get back with your sister
was like damn this sounds good typical
Alabama
yeah no like I think I think the good
thing was was that uh my family was
never a family that would like hold
grudges or anything so like no matter
how bad the fight was or no matter how
bad the quarrels might have been like
the next day it was always like no let's
just like you know we're still family at
the end of the day let's just leave that
behind us and you know yeah have a good
day yeah because it's always been weird
for me as like hearing about sibling
kind of like you know uh life uh because
I think the closest thing I have is my
cousins I think that's the reason I'm so
[__] close to most of my cousins
because I have a lot of my cousins are
only only children like me
um but like we have like I guess a
similar bond without going through all
the fighting that I hear that siblings
go through and I I think that's just
because when we see each other
um you know there was only like a few
times that we would able you know I
actually when we were kids we hung out
quite a lot but we didn't have to see
each other every single day yeah uh yeah
I can't imagine how I can't imagine how
that is yeah so just just imagine like
you know uh like like just think of like
your I don't know if you have a favorite
cousin but like think think of your
favorite cousin and just imagine like
living with them every day for the first
20 years of your life yeah right that's
basically what it's like well the
sibling Dynamics kind of like accurate
is it just like is it like the youngest
one gets like the most spoiled on the
most attention
no I think it depends on the parents
I've like as as the oldest sibling was
it like did your parents look at you to
like look after your sister oh totally
okay yeah normally the oldest has the
most responsibility that's pretty yeah
it's like hey can you can you be can you
take care of them but I think it might I
think in my case it was a bit different
because I think if we had to compare
like who got spoiled more it might have
been my sister just because like she was
the daughter of the family right whereas
like oh Sydney definitely got the sport
the [__] status right yeah it's
always it's most of the time it's the
daughter that gets spoiled by the dad
right you know and uh and then the the
sun aka me would be like all right I'm
gonna whip you in a [__] [__]
no holds bar you though you're the one
doing the discipline I'm gonna make you
a man
how did that work out
um Dad I think you failed